hello everybody my name is Mark I'm here
with Toby right now we're gonna play
some dog dog
oh geez back here you little plan you
know this is a setup it's hot in it Oh
where's your skin
[Applause]
[Music]
I'm sorry I apologize I'm going it's
eating the line yeah it's - the soup
yeah so in reality who is who is the
real loser in this one I mean I guess
yeah nice to you to give you some my
bursts of seppuku towards you so you
seppuku me yeah
thank you for supercooling it I mean
then you don't suicide and then more
stuff from next times to puku yourself
alright so doing the clouds you up this
place for this time I need to hear this
happening okay
[Music]
Oh
[Music]
[Music]
I was you died in this hog Oh times
we're even in terms of freaking we're
always even in terms of skill you are
you barely you don't scream as much
she's not your louder than I know how
you have that base thing going but
you're going like way sir you're going
like like internal mines this external
wiggle worm yeah I thought you didn't
have anymore
no I course I wanted you didn't see me
things you ever get the LASIK probably
not phasers are awesome dude not any
chance you get
yeah kids don't punch it I'm trying to
do masculine steps ever doing no
matching what's the least max killing
way to take cans
I got pig shams I like this right here
up up down
I know bless your face off yeah I love
you
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
what oh you are just messed up
[Laughter]